write your truth
and believe in it and if your mother
doesn't like it
too bad
the novel is creating a whole new mode
of understanding the world
over the last 30 years of being a
novelist i've
learned how that's worked and i've made
a commitment to it
and i would love to talk to you about
that commitment
i'm going to talk to you about how to
choose the right words
structure story characters
to create the novel that's in you the
black male heroes are the major
characters
in my novels because there have been
very few novels written about black male
heroes
if you want to be in the history of the
culture
then you have to exist in the fiction
if you don't exist in the literature
your people don't exist
i wake up write three hours thousand
words
next day the first thing i do is reread
that thousand words i wrote yesterday
and then i write my next thousand words
and that goes on
and on until i get to the end of the
novel if you write
every day the next day ideas have
bubbled up from some place
that you had no idea were there one of
the great things about starting
writing for me at the age of 34
was that i was already a failure in life
in failing
you can find out the right way of doing
things
a lot of you will be intimidated to
start writing
throw all that fear out the window it
doesn't matter because it doesn't
the only thing i need you to leave this
class with
is the confidence that you can write a
knob
you will write that now i couldn't ask
for anything more
i'm walter mosley and this
is my master class
[Music]
you